الان الى التطورات في الضفه الغربيه حيث
افاد مراس الجزيره كما اسلفنا باغتيال
ثلاثه مقاومين بعد الاشتباك معهم شرق طول
كرم بالضفه الغربيه حول هذا الخبر معنا من
طول كرم مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث ضعنا
في صوره هذه التطورات ما الذي حدث وكيف تم
اغتيال هؤلاء
القاده نعم بالفعل عمليه عسكريه ومجزره
جديده في مدينه طول كرم شمال الضفه
الغربيه الم متل هذه المنطقه في ضاحيه
كتابه الى الشمال من المحافظه حيث وصلت
وصلت وحدات خاصه اسرائيليه الى هذه
المنطقه من حاجز 104 وصل الى هذه المنطقه
هذه المنطقه تقع
بين مخيمي طول كرم ونور شمس حيث تم
استهداف مجموعه من المقاومين هنا كان في
على هذا الطريق مقاومين اثنين والثالث كان
ايضا في هذا المنزل حيث كان متواجد هنا
على على على الطريق او على مدخل المنزل
حيث تم استهدافه من قبل القوات الخاصه
الاسرائيليه ما ادى الى
استشهاد الفلسطينيين والمقاومين الثلاث في
هذه المنطقه قوات الخاصه حاصرت هذه
المنطقه دفعت بالتعزيز العسكريه
الاسرائيليه الى هذه المنطقه حيث بدات
اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه في هذه المنطقه ايه
ب بعد وصول التعزيزات العسكريه من شارع
السكه وصولا الى ضاحيه كتابه ومحاصر
المنطقه باكملها حيث بدات بدا الاحتلال
بسحب المقاومين الثلاثه من من الى الطريق
الرئيسي ومن ثم قام بحسب شهود عيان بسحب
احد المقاومين عبر اليه عسكريه ومن ثم ايه
اي يعني ايه تقدمت اليه عسكريه نحو جثمان
احد الشهداء وقامت بدهسه ما ادى الى صعوبه
في التعرف عليه ثلاثه مقاومين وصلوا
بالفعل الى مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي في
مدينه طول كرم حيث تم التعرف عليهم بشكل
رسمي من قبل المستشفى ووزاره الصحه ليرتفع
عدد الشهداء منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى
340 شهيدا في الضفه الغربيه المح سله
المجازر الاسرائيليه متواصله في الضفه
الغربيه هنا في هذه المنطقه على غرار ما
حدث امس في مدينه جنين وتحديدا قريه
الشهداء في المدينه حيث تم استهداف سبعه
مقاومين او سبعه مواطنين ومدنيين في
المخيم اثناء انسحاب جيش الاحتلال هذه
اثار الدماء للشهداء الذين استشهدوا بعد
المجزره الاسرائيليه التي وقعت في هذه
المنطقه مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من مدينه
طول كرم
الفلسطينيه